exciting news from the world of
extremism a Nation of Islam leader and
known anti-semite Louis Farrakhan has
added himself to the list of racist
supporting Donald Trump's candidacy for
president he praised Donald Trump during
a sermon earlier this month
or late February I guess it is at this
point saying that Donald Trump is the
only one of the current candidates who
is not being controlled by the Jews
according to the anti-defamation league
Farrakhan told parishioners of Chicago's
mosque Maryam Sunday that Trump quote is
the only member who has stood in front
of Jewish communities and said I don't
want your money
going on to say any time a man can say
that to those who control the politics
of America I don't want your money
that means you can't control me as you
know Louis I know you're a big a student
of Louis Farrakhan in the critical sense
Farrakhan has a long history of
anti-semitic comments he said Jews were
behind 9/11 he said that God was the one
who put Jews in the oven referring of
course to the Holocaust his praise of
Trump is interesting in its timing
because former Klansmen David Duke Grand
Wizard or supreme supreme which I can't
ever remember what his thing was David
Duke endorsed Donald Trump and then now
Louis Farrakhan endorses Donald Trump
normally David Duke and Louis Farrakhan
would hate each other they're both
behind Trump it's very compelling yes I
guess Farrakhan might not know that
Donald Trump has Jewish family members
okay but it's interesting that he can
put aside Donald Trump's at least the
appearance of Donald Trump's Muslim
xenophobia right because he believes
Trump is not beholding to Jews remember
that Donald Trump did actually speak to
a room of Republican Jews and said you
won't support me because I don't want
your money so the comment is not
completely out of left field in a sense
but what we can take away from this is
that Donald Trump is truly a uniter
right I mean all of a sudden you have
KKK leaders former KKK leaders and
Nation of Islam leaders saying Trump is
the guy this is a type of uniting that
certainly we haven't seen in a very long
time have
but what happens when you put all of
these new supporters in in the same
Donald Trump party yeah you know viewing
party what happens then today do they
hold hands I I know what you're saying
louis farrakhan david duke and chris
christie all saying this is the best
candidate it's stunning stunning and
shocking to all no question about it